happy to see everybody here this is my
first live talk in over i can't remember
how many months years never mind i
really hope this talk is informative
and
let's let's dive in
so a little bit about my background i
consider myself sort of on one trick
pony who's worked way too long in one
thing uh distributed databases and i
really started uh on this journey at
uh you know oracle distribu like
change capture uh
you know log log replication and that
sort of stuff and then i know
linkedin i let the voldemort key value
store
during the kind of the hyper growth kind
of phases at linkedin
then i had a brief stinted box where we
building one more real-time data store
uh like i love firebase
and uh most recently i was at compliment
right before this journey building k
sequel streaming database
and of course hoodie is a project that
we started well i was a duper and been
also you know growing the community with
the purchase of a foundation for the
last five years
and with one house we're doing
more of the same distributed data
warehouses database
these stuff so
that's my background and
you know for today
um i've done a lot of hoodie talks so
that's not what we're going to do today
um you know there's a lot of good good
materials out there for hoodie on the
side and you can always connect over the
hoodie slack
instead
what we noticed is everybody knows what
viruses are and then i used to assume
that everybody knew in my own bubble
that people knew what data lakes were
and over the past one year i've actually
realized that it it's not the the
community is big and it's not
necessarily the case and then now there
is you know the new kid on the blog
with the lake house so
um like you know besides hoodie we can't
i get a lot of questions in the
community around like general
architecture how to think about things
should i move out should i stay like you
know all kind of things so i thought i
will take some time
to talk through some of these uh you
know aspects and sort of clarify some
common common questions here
okay
all right so why now right so why is it
important to do that now and i'm
actually over the last two years i
realized how big the data community was
uh uh sorry has become right and then uh
we have people with very diverse set of
backgrounds actually so i have a more
database background i'm pretty sure a
lot of you are from the spark kind of
like world uh streaming fling and python
as we just saw like in the in the great
uh keynote and a lot of display now
plain old sequel okay let's write sequel
right this also that camp
and there are lots of choices in front
of us right so how do we pick and choose
and how do we understand tradeoffs
together that's sort of what what we
hope to do today
and a quick overview so we'll first
start by sketching the evolution of
these technologies the arc of sort of
how we got here
and sort of try to understand and study
them across these three different
aspects which is architecture
capabilities price performance
and
i'll leave you with
a pattern that i've seen emerge you know
this is broadly distilling the kind of
patterns that i've seen in the hoodie
community for a more balanced and future
proof way to kind of like build your
data architect core data infrastructure
and architecture
so let's let's get started so
on-prem data arrows is you know very
simple right like there are special you
can think of them as specialized
databases for analytics that's that's
all we had and then if you look at the
other arc data lakes really started out
as a
architectural pattern more than anything
else not not tangible software that you
can download and use like an rdbms or a
warehouse it's more like an
architectural pattern that's how we
started in the 2000s
and steadily you know you've seen in the
last uh decade like
bigquery um serverless queries there's
steadily lots of innovation has happened
around the warehousing space redshift in
my opinion really broke uh you know
brought cloud warehouses like mainstream
uh as the cloud like picked up a lot of
momentum
and of course snowflake like famously
decoupled the storage and
compute here and with a lot of great
usability and today you have the cloud
warehousing options which are like you
know premature a lot of people use it
for as a stable
uh analytics needs right
and if you look at going back to the
data lakes uh
really like all of this started with
more search and social and these kind of
high scale data use cases i used to work
at linkedin again back when you know
we're using all of these things to build
process a lot of data and build data
driven products really
and for a while that's you know like
even as
spark grew and and sort of
revolutionized data processing
and uh cloud grew you know a lot of the
workloads the cloud the cloud storage is
ubiquitous
data lake slowly became pretty much
synonymous with files on top of cloud
storage right
and
we had an interesting thing uh at like
point at uber back then when we were
trying to build a textbook data
architecture which is
a data lake architecture where we wanted
to essentially you know get our
operational data our databases event
streams and external sources
into a raw sort of like layer
uh reflect that and then be able to do
any kind of like etl or post processing
derive more data sets out of it it we
found that it was pretty impossible to
build that textbook architecture because
so the the core capabilities that you
needed to
transactional capabilities that you
needed were just simply lacking uh on
the warehouse sorry on the data lakes
and that's how the hoodie project was
born so we basically
added updates deletes transactions and
also even like going ask for to add
database cdc style uh change streams uh
on top of the links and this is what we
called a transactional data lake that's
what we call it uh internally uh back
then and
uh as you know right after uh some some
like quickly right off right databricks
delta started out as a proprietary uh
project and then was open sourced a few
years later and over the last couple
years i think we've seen this term uh
lake house really being like popularized
uh to sort of uh mark this
shift in technology for how we store and
manage data on the data lake
i don't think we need more battles
around names and terminologies this term
is catchy and we can like i feel like we
can use this to just talk about
transactional data lakes so
moving forward so why did why this
matters now is as a technology i've had
this like question a lot which is oh is
it marketing or is it like there's still
work to be done but the technology
foundations on what this technology adds
on top of the existing data lakes it's
pretty prone out so just from looking at
the apache hoodie community through that
lens right you can see like these are uh
everyday daily services and sorry even
like large enterprises that you see uh
you know if you like add them all
together you're looking at a few extra
bytes of data being managed uh you know
using uh like you know a lego stick like
apache hoodie
so the tech is really
there and it's you might have noticed
all the recent developments and all the
and someone who started my career in in
like watching the database wars it found
it like very interesting uh to say the
least
and okay so how do you make sense of it
all what's really going on and and this
picture actually summarizes it well like
warehouses are pretty well understood
everybody understands what they're for
they're like pretty much sure and data
lakes have been in this trough of
distribution month from pretty much 2018
to 2020 you know till now right and then
there's a lot of frustration around data
engineering there's like too many moving
pieces
out there
and then lake house is just like an
emerging category which i believe can
redeem rheem like lakes by adding
some of the core missing functionality
that that you that you see
right
but
we need to be also pretty cautious uh
because this is not the first time
around that you know uh we've seen a
silver bullet being
sort of you know prescribed to solve all
problems
right and and and i'm
unfortunately getting old enough to have
lived through the hadoop era promises
where the hadoop enterprise data
warehouse you can read these like titles
yourself you know would take over data
warehousing and all that and and to me
it was a little bit ahead of its time
for the bet but also
there's like you know a lot of focus
away from solving core
user problems right the things like
hurry should have been written like way
like five years before in my opinion and
uh
so that that's the thing so we also need
to approach it with like more cautious
optimism so throughout today i'll try to
like kind of give give a more like an
open honest like evaluation of where
things are today and how how i see uh
like you know the landscape evolving as
well
so we'll cover three aspects one is
architecture design considerations what
are the primary workloads what is it
like of course like functionally
everything can sit on everything but
what is it really like built for
and and we'll also talk about openness
because that comes up a lot whenever you
talk about architecture so open
architectures are like a thing right
and we'll touch upon some core technical
capabilities how well these things are
platformized you know uh what does the
management look like you know how much
do you need you should plan for your
team building versus like how much is
already built in how much flexibility
you want versus how much is like
pre-baked like that sort of thing that
matters a lot today in terms of like
devops and operating lean
data arcs right and cost performance
levers so this like variety of workloads
i'll leave you with like you know what
are the type of workloads what is you
know what are the design choices how
they kind of like sit on of the stacks
so let's quickly look at like the basics
which is what is the on-prem uh
warehouse so pretty much you had a bunch
of nodes with beefy disks and cpu and
you ran sql which ran on them access
local data right it's pretty like it's
just a clustered database kind of
architecture the real kind of like
innovation and again like it's hard to
really picture uh architecture of closed
systems right and and i think more or
less more i think high level they look
like this i think um you have storage on
cloud storage which is like infinitely
scalable right so so the problem with on
on-prem warehouses was that the storage
and the the
compute were coupled so you cannot
independently scale them both right but
but in this model cloud warehouse they
sold it really well where you can store
as much data as you want in a cloud
storage with of course some caveats but
then you can spin up on demand compute
and the these are managed services which
always keep some always on platform
services like you know optimizing your
queries transaction management metadata
these help these services be more
resilient they can do a lot of globally
you know optimal additions like you may
be spinning up virtual warehouses on the
same table and like you can you can do a
lot of cross uh optimizations that way
so this this is the architecture that
we've seen and if you now go go over to
the lake uh traditional data lakes it's
interestingly it's always had the
storage and compute separation that's
actually literally how they were born
but the traditional data lake was pretty
much files on
top and you know you had a mixture of
json like anything really right and uh
sql engines essentially a bunch of nodes
that can execute sql
on top of them depending on the engine
and the vendor you use you either had a
cache or not
with lacos is what we've really done is
added a layer insert a layer in between
and track more metadata and then you
would see that it it's become more
structured the world is more structured
now in the lake house
and uh essentially we added a
transaction management layer uh like a
bunch of things that can optimize your
tables similar to what you find in the
warehouse like you know clustering your
table and whatnot we'll talk about some
of these later
and also like schema management or
statistics just tracking more scalable
file level statistics for for your
tables
and rest of the architecture is pretty
much you know the same and you can now
see how the architectures kind of
approach each other right from the
from the cloud warehousing on the lake
lake house model
an openness is a big topic right and
then it it simply doesn't stop with open
data formats it's uh it extends well
beyond cuts into architecture so of
course like you know open data formats
are interoperable future proof uh
warehouses pretty much more or less
proprietary data formats and the
interoperability is a different thing if
you're really popular then
lot of tools will interoperate with you
but with open file and sort of like
table formats what you really get is the
ecosystem can evolve on its own no
you're not really beholden by a vendor
really adding support for some xyz
formats really that's that's the key
power of of having data open data
formats and data location access again
it actually varies between vendors uh
even warehouses in some used or data
with the virusing vendor on some it's
like cloud provider operator warehouses
then it sits within your account so it
kind of like varies uh lakes mostly
store data in your own uh bucket and
uh with some caveats that you know you
need to be careful about how you really
set up permissions on your bucket so
that you can remain owners owner of the
objects that you've written right
um data services is one of the key
differences that i find are
most of the
things that operate on a warehouse that
maintain your manager tables are all
proprietary and on the lake even on the
lake i think there's a pattern to like
keep open formats but lock everything
else to like a vendor runtime and this
is something that we've done i would say
a much better job at on the huri project
where you get like you know in just
services table optimization all these
services are in open source and the
combination is what at least in our
opinion logs through kind of like
openness because then
just a format is a passive thing right
what do you do with it
so on code and community again like can
you influence the project can you get
you know even if you have a team
like you know if it's large enterprises
are tied to vendor roadmaps and even on
the lake it kind of varies by the
project and whether it's a grassroots
open source project or it's like a more
vendor like driven by one company sort
of thing right so
and and i'll
so i had a quick like sidebar on data
mesh where i get a lot of people oh i'm
building a mesh and not a lake uh so
just just quick thing here is it's
pretty orthogonal concept the mesh talks
really about the if you remember i said
data lake was an architectural concept
it mostly talks about how you organize
your data not the data infra so even
here if you look at even this like
introductory
sort of article it advocates for data
infra standardization uh as a as a key
point of how you can implement a
data mesh
so summarizing our architectural
discussion right so
tldr what we what i see today is like
warehouses are really built for bi where
the problem is about scanning the least
amount of data possible
and that's because they have performance
metadata management long-running servers
you know generally it's geared towards
sort of supporting these more
interactive workloads better
and
if you look at the lake support scalable
ai what it really means is they're
they're scan optimized they can
scan vast amounts of data that's because
like all of them hit
that no intermediate servers right so
they can directly access cloud storage
and open formats really mean that the
kind of ecosystem that we just like
talked about in the keynote these kinds
of ecosystems can evolve much more
quickly
because smaller projects can come up
they can be built on top of this data
and then it's easy to do that evolve and
i trade as a community
and lake houses in some sense are trying
to blend both but there are challenges i
i reckon there'll be like a lot more
query planning like these kinds of
advancements needed and i mean if you
google any lake versus warehouse sara
lake comparison it'll tell you
structured unstructured right legos are
still mostly like dealing with
structured data and we haven't even run
and and then there's like still a lot
more standardized data management and
these challenges to be solved
so it's impossible to like look at every
technical capability but hopefully uh
these slides will give you a uh you know
a
picture and establish a pattern of you
know the the theme that you can observe
so just core reading and writing right
at this point all of them can support
insert updates delete you know uh
transactions statistics sorting
bulk loads audit you know rollbacks time
travel this kind of basic functionality
you'll find in all the stacks
uh you'll find that warehouses have more
complete like relational or database
like functionality like multi-table
transactions or you know clustering and
these kind of things and on the lake
house most of this tech is delivered as
libraries right as you know and your
mileage really varies with like kind of
the libraries that you use uh hoodie for
example you supported keys from the get
go because that was like a unique unique
key constraint was like a pretty
hard requirement for us when we started
it back at uber and uh then you have
like space filling curves you will find
some are prime proprietary some are open
and then there are some specific design
choices around like streaming updates
and all these things like so
in general you will feel you will see
that the the
lakers
design choices reflect more
around the highest higher scale data
needs at this point
uh while
various try to stay close to the
database sort of origins that they start
with
the other set of things that you need is
it's not just like you know writing a
bunch of data and then walking away you
need like some services that can
at the core optimize your tables you
know ensure really good performance and
i've listed some of them here and you
can see like a pattern here right so
like
you know clustering or sorting for good
performance space reclamation so when
you see dirty data you know how is it is
it like managed and and there's a huge
difference in terms of how automatically
managed they are and and or whether you
need to take some of these libraries on
the lake and then
run them yourself
right
and uh something like file sizing is
completely like viruses hide files right
but
they're still exposed on the lake and
and if you don't manage them well they
can you know affect your performance and
some frameworks have automatic
enforcement some are diy so you'll find
like a mix of uh you know management
gaps or
uh or maybe like even in hoodie right we
we have these things but you still need
to self-manage it like hoodie can do
clustering but you need to run a
clustering job yourself uh and then kind
of operate it while well if you just
go with a managed service these are like
managed uh internally for you
right i'm talking about caching it's
like pretty transparent and and
depending on the vendor you will either
get caching or not on the lake
and there's also other things that you
need to generally build
a warehouse and like you know kind of
like like declare it open for your
company things like database change
capture or even ingesting log events and
things like that
so here what i've seen is a lot of
people who use cloud uh the modern data
stack of the cloud data warehousing
space have managed zero ops injection
services that they prefer to get data in
and like you know sort of build tables
but on the lake people hand roll their
own debisium or dms or some like change
capture thing uh tie it to a library
like hoodie to build an end-to-end like
system and then sort of operate it
so
big uh the big takeaway here is still if
you want to build a like a lake lake
house today and operationalize it does
take some time
and
you have to build it sort of like brick
by break by looking at all these
different
kind of
problems and problem spaces and putting
solutions together which gives you great
flexibility but it does take some time
time to market for you to operationalize
this
this is a very interesting topic so
price performance so
first
let's try to think about the different
workloads you have often i find that
whenever people talk about price
performance you just see some tpcds wars
and some numbers being thrown right in
reality you have at least these four
different
kinds of like workloads right and not
not all of them uh need a premium engine
meaning uh you know your sql
optimizations aren't necessarily going
to help you with ingestion right it's a
very i o bound thing where you can
afford to not run premium like uh engine
so we'll get into that a little bit
and different workloads of different
price performance that's that's what i'm
trying to emphasize here
and
you know like locking yourself to like
one engine uh basically you're just like
buying
one and especially on the lake where
you don't really ha like you still have
to do a lot of work to manage your
tables you have the optionality of
picking the right engine so you for some
maybe you pick open source version some
we go with the vendor so lake is good in
the sense that you give that optionality
but with with the arrows it's more or
less priced in right all of these things
are priced in for you
so
this is the famous tpcds wars that you
always read right we're going to do
something different we're going to try
to understand the anatomy of a query so
what really happens and then how do each
component and a lake house or warehouse
sort of like react
uh on to each of these segments and
where does the performance difference
come from
so one is fetching metadata right so
if you look at like just table metadata
schema statistics and like whatever is
needed for you to plan and then like
just understand how to even plan this
query
lake houses like store today either in
like a meta store like hive or like flat
files which store like statistics about
the table and then various predominantly
use a database to store that cs 101 will
tell you that databases will outperform
flat files for a wide range of
things when the data size is like big
right so that the same laws apply
and i think it's still like like early
days uh and we have to evolve the the
statistics management in the lakers uh
beyond this i feel right
and if you go to query planning then you
know it depends on like pretty much the
engine and the vendor this is where most
of the
engine open sources like vendor
proprietary kind of like uh
margins and all the the the competitive
ips built and uh just going by the
problem space right the the query
optimization is a very hard problem
which gets like better with the amount
of time you spend in it just by that i i
would imagine like there'll be like much
more mature optimizers out there and and
this is like a evolving landscape right
once you plan a query when you execute
it if you look at it legos like we
employ open file formats and on the
varus there's close file formats i i
don't think a lot of the performance
come differences come from the file
format themselves but more like how run
time off if you do a group by query
let's say you have to shuffle data
around
how how does the engine do it and even
within the lake engines there is like
huge variants right something like spark
would
uh you know
be more resilient to shuffle failures
retry and but something like presto
wants to keep the interactive query
performance and the lower latency so it
probably like it will fail and it'll do
like a different choices when it
shuffles data and answers queries
so
high level answer it depends uh tpcds is
great but i've routinely found that
people run their own workloads and then
they find that it's actually not the gap
isn't this that big or it isn't that
small like you know always test with
your own like you know key table take
your top five queries or something and
then try to test uh that that's what i'd
say and and this table gives you like a
good sense right so over the base ec2
cost
you have
different sort of like engines pricing
differently
this
is
this benefits you b when
you know for cost price performance
let's say your your
engine increases
charges you 2x more but can finish that
query like you know three x faster than
the net you gain right in cost
but uh it's not the case everywhere
right and they need to think about does
everything need to be fast because
caches are pretty fast
uh as well for example but they cost
money right so
if if you can afford to be slower in
some cases it can be cheaper as well so
it's more nuanced like fastest is in the
the thing and when you look at varroa's
pricing as well some price by query some
price uh
on like a different kind of virtual like
instance types which it's hard to map to
cloud so it's a it's a little bit of a
complicated uh thing out there but the
main thing to understand is benchmark
your own workloads and sort of like
understand what workload needs to go
where
but the main thing i want to stress is
the the case of the that's the missing
benchmark so what surprisingly what i've
noticed is etl workloads uh
a lot of times don't get that much
attention even though like a lot of
people spend a bunch of time on it right
uh because the problem of
you know computing derived data sets out
of all the data that your your company
is collecting every day is very
different from trying to answer a kind
of like a more selective query where
you're trying to figure out okay give me
the sales by for this region uh or like
a dashboarding problem like that right
and actually there's like a benchmark
tpcdi for data integration but i rarely
see anybody reporting anything around it
and at least from from our experience
what we've seen is if you look at the
patterns on the right they depict like a
fact table
an event table and some dimension table
being updated you can see that the
update patterns are really very
different uh we don't believe like you
know uh all these workloads are same so
we we need like better
standardization and this is this is
something that i see regularly people
hitting but there is not enough out
there in terms of standardized
benchmarks to compare all of these
things or not
and finally these data optimizations
really do matter and then we we have
very little here as well in terms of
okay how does file sizing affect query
performance like do you take more hit on
the right versus the read and how do
like uh and then uh as as we've seen
right these are two
um studies of how clustering can improve
performance one from like on on hoodie
one from aws one it's from our own blogs
and open source
yeah you can carefully control data
layout but how do you do it across like
hundreds of tables without kind of
really you know having side effects how
do you globally optimize for cost and by
data layout control these are like
pretty open problems and and
like a lot of people have to hand tune
and spend a lot of time today to like
squeeze value out of these techniques
so
let's i want to basically summarize and
just like leave you with some food for
thought
right in in all what we're saying here
is uh
you know the various stack is more uh
closed
the lakes are more open conditions apply
meaning like really depends on how
you're building your lake
and
um
it's built for
you know bi predominantly uh
and you know
things like lake lakes if you look at
every like large tech companies who
built on after lakes they it's proven
out right that they have the scale and
the support for advanced analytics or
data science
the by and far fully managed
and here what you'll find is i do
routinely find that that it takes like
few months for people to even you know
the hoodie community we have like uh you
know like a streaming just service and a
whole bunch of things but you still need
to take it learn it operate it you need
to like there's a ramping curve for
people so it's like diy and a little bit
difficult to operationalize i would say
and here um
it's expensive as you scale
but it's cheaper as you scale meaning
when you when by scale i mean your your
workloads
get more heavy or your data volume grows
or your r grow even uh grows
so
for to like this is what i the common
pattern i see uh when and this is a
question that i've been asked a lot it's
just like when do people adopt a lake
so
commonly you start like this right it's
a very simple like you know replicate
your operational data in
and then you have some dashboards most
people are happy there and then even
with like modest data size growth then
you start getting into doing some etls
on the on the warehouse
then eventually you know you either hit
cost or you know you the company is big
enough where you care about open
openness open formats all the stuff that
we talked about
and uh you know you form a data science
team here
and they will tell you that oh let's go
instrument the app with lots of events
and this i've seen a lot from my my time
at confluent and also with the kafka
experience uh over the years
and mostly you'll see that the even data
you know lands on the lake and
then you start writing some etls which
need to be fed some data from the
warehouse you also copy
you know any etls that you offloaded
from the warehouse you start copying the
data back as well so most people are in
this kind of like
world where
there isn't a single you know source for
lineage for your data
so so we feel like you know um
instead of like polarizing the world
into these kind of like two camps like
if you we take a step back and think
about
from a user like organization standpoint
what what we would need i would distill
it down to like these this kind of like
five pillars which i've seen again
uh companies eventually come to realize
and adopt
one is interoperable so
the lake houses have to be interoperable
even with like warehouses like why not
that the data is there you should be
able to it's another engine that can
query so why shouldn't you be able to do
that
and across all lake engines like you
know you should be able to
access the data right cross cutting
because today if you look at these three
things there's at least three ways to
buy this right or use it like open
source or there's usually a company
behind some of these engines are from
directly from the cloud provider they'll
offer you a wash like a packaged version
right
and
there should be easy uptake for a new
tech like you know vendors shouldn't be
controlling a lot of the interop as much
uh today as they are because these
formats and these kind of low level
pieces become kind of you know anchor
points to build sort of like some sort
of like lock-in right so
and
more and more keep data on the lake by
that what i mean is like open data
formats we've seen
vendors sort of like rise and fall but
the data sits there right um and
i think overall i feel in in in the last
five years i've seen that
replicating your database changes or all
your raw operational data directly onto
the lake in an open format
sets you up really well for the future
because it's the most voluminous uh data
sets usually uh even on the warehouse
what usually affects your cost is the
the
raw etl to like in the first layer of
landing it in the warehouse and then you
know doing a dvd to get your tables
that's the etl cost that i've seen so
this sets you really up for that and you
can always recompute anything right you
can switch query engines you can
recompute you get this like really great
flexibility in this architecture
and uh
most importantly i think this is like
very understated this now feeds a single
source of truth uh meaning like a single
the same data feeds into both bi and
your data science teams which means like
they they can just worry about the data
like you know they don't they don't have
a lot of these data quality
uh
surprises they can just focus on like
you know how their analysis is wrong or
the query is wrong rather than you know
about whether we were fed different
inputs
and as much as possible we can manage a
lot on the lake because it doesn't need
premium compute a lot of these
management services are more
like i o bound or external interactions
not all the all the sql optimizations
don't really count
right
and uh yeah we need a lot more a lot
more here in terms of uh
management and again we live in a world
of specialized engines so we really need
to plan for that
and external tables on the warehouses
today i don't know if they are on par
with their native formats right so that
needs to improve and
and then we can have a world where we
can have also cost effective etl where
we leave the big batch jobs on the lake
and then going back right all your raw
data most voluminous data sets are in
open format on the lake
and uh you can write like small etls
anywhere it's fine like there
and but but
by and large i think we should move more
towards an incremental model uh because
still you're writing batch etls
everywhere right
so what does it look like
um it looks like this you go into
directly to a lake house or and it's
like open it has all the
interoperability
and you can write etls there in a cost
effective way it's already ml data is
ready and then if you can get the data
in quickly uh even your etls and the utl
data out into the warehouse or directly
query them
uh you're gonna get like really good
performance for bi and reporting
and you can even explore a lot of these
new you know
ml or even streaming like a lot of these
new emerging areas can be well
integrated because again it's an open
format and the ecosystem can evolve on
its own not beholden to vendors
and
yeah of course like this is proven out
to support data science and engineering
right
so this this is what like i've seen a
lot of companies like kind of settle
over i'll be happy to take more more of
these uh questions uh right after in the
officers as well
and uh
yeah thanks for thanks for being uh here
and i know some of these slides were
came a little wonky so i apologize for
that i don't know what happened
but uh yeah that's it from me
[Applause]
you